attack down service attacking it's my
feet I yell who is at the Technion and
has been doing watching research for one
of the first people I know who started
the existence a so let's that's what
could be tired thanks very much of me
I'll talk today like I said about a
specific attack a blockchain
denial-of-service attack it's an attack
that stops blockchain much cheaper than
was possible before society aspect here
is I guess that we'll need to to think
about how we incentivize good behavior
through society because as we see the
internal incentives option have some
issues here so this is work with my
student Michael working at the Technion
eunji in re Jules at Cornell Tech and
Aria clogs moon and Jonathan pang at
Cornell
so first of all why denial-of-service
attacks so this is the top 10
cryptocurrencies by market cap and these
are the ones 80% that use Nakamoto
proof-of-work blockchain to secure their
funds a total of 165 billion US dollars
five days ago today to complete a
different number but still in this area
these these are all affected but by what
I'm going to tell you about today but
first why why'd denial-of-service why
would we want to stop a blockchain there
could be several reasons and despite
these reasons block trains have
demonstrated unprecedented resilience
these are open systems anyone can join
in yet they have been stable the major
ones at least for a decade since Bitcoin
came to be so why would anyone choose to
stop a blockchain so it could be
competition it is either from a state
and picking one at random here but the
decides that this is not a good again
they have the facilities to actually try
to block a chain and it could be because
of a fight between two block chains that
one wants to take the participants from
the other it also can be for immediate
immediate gains even if there's just one
currency you might want to stop it
interfere it immediately causing
immediately causing a deterioration in
the exchange rate and so making some
money on the side yeah extortion or
ransom fearless
as a reason to stop the entire chain
explain I mean what's the benefit
somebody pays you the ransom possibly
like you can send up a smart contract on
a cerium that's paying for Bitcoin
jandial of service down when it's
received if you want to interfere in
some process yeah I guess it's a more
extreme case of what I wrote there is a
short-selling yeah
so there are there ways we know how to
do denial of service and to go through
these I want to do the short background
slides so in normal chain lock chain in
the kimono change situation we have the
miners extending the chain and they add
blocks one after the other and there
might be a fork so in case of a fork the
two miners know Mel intention form two
branches and now in akimoto says that we
follow the longest chain so eventually
one chain is going to be longer and all
the miners are going to join the longest
chain and continue there everything is
fine how does this become a
denial-of-service attack with an
attacker that has 51% to a majority of
the mining power in the system we have
all the miners trying to extend the
chain and attacker miners are in
majority honest miners that are not
trying to attack the system extend the
chain and the attackers simply ignore
the honest block and they extend their
own chain and they place an empty block
and because they're a majority they
they're able to extend faster than the
honest parties their chain becomes
longer the honest part is follow the
mungus chain because it's the longest
chain and the honest block gets lost and
this goes on and on and we're able to
have a chain full of only empty blocks
so we managed to do a denial of service
though this is very expensive we can
also attack individual nodes we
community not myself with an eclipse
attack this looks like this we want to
attack a specific node so we do a
network attack on that specific node
then we prevent it from accessing the
block chain this doesn't require as many
resources but it only as much resources
many resources but it only effects a
single node and what we're talking here
is a block chain denial of service
attack we want to stop the entire chain
and the key point is incentives we are
go the attacker is going to motivate the
honest players to not mine
she's going to do that by showing that
she's ahead she's able she's she has
some blocks and it's not worthwhile for
the honest miners to mine
so a natural way to do this with today's
mechanisms of Bitcoin and family is to
use the what's called SPD mining so SPV
or show a simplified payment
verification is a technique an important
technique that allows participants that
used lightweight devices to get
reasonable confidence that their
transactions are on the chain and this
happens by showing that a transaction of
the user is inside the block without
providing the entire block and this
happened because in the header there is
America route and no that has all the
information can present the merkel proof
and show that show the user of the
lightweight client that they have a
transaction in that block so this is a
benign positive technique this becomes a
problem with SPV mining so that's we've
been mining what happened is that a
miner mines on partial blocks or block
where the miner only has the header this
happens in real life because the miners
can get a miner with a no advantage of
being able to start mining early when
they know that there is a block coming
and we we see this if you look at a
blockchain is something see empty blocks
these are likely they're only the result
of such SPV mining that is the following
that the miner is imagining that he
already has the full block and he
produces his new block and the header
has enough information to do this so the
miner produces a block and once the full
block is exposed here the chain can
continue and our attack attacker is
going to to utilize this by publishing
only a header and never the full block
we'll see how so the the the entire
thing relies on incentives it relies on
this this insight from from the selfish
mining work that these two are different
so if everyone else is honest in the
minority attacker cannot validate it
cannot violate
this this is something we know from
Bitcoin from day one but this is not the
same and saying that if everyone else is
honest then the minority player should
be honest this is what we're going to
play with
doesn't begin by describing our model so
we have a system with n minors the
attacker is going to be external and
given a chain a minor can do the
following things they can mine on the
longest chain as they should they can
SPV mine on the longest chain including
blocks that have only the header
this is something we know that they do
not very desirable but it happened and
they can decide to stop so they don't
mind you just turn off there and there
are mining rigs there mining machines
they don't waste any money but they also
do not produce any block and this is
kind of similar to what caste and
friends called pati compliance so we're
limiting our world to a situation where
the miners are kind of honest they don't
behave arbitrarily they don't try to
initiate their own deviations from the
protocol
now the system progresses in rounds
locks every time the block is produced
they continue the scheduler chooses who
will produce the block at random
depending on miners mining side and
expenses only occur when the miner is
working again this is similar to Carlson
companies work and the gap game but we
encapsulate this in the standard model
for analyzing blockchain so we say when
there is no during the period where
there is no mining the when a miner
chooses not to mine they're not spending
any effort and I'm going to take off the
table immediately the the idea of
changing your strategy while you're
running and I don't want to get into the
details but because the interval between
blocks is memory less than basically we
can assume that no players don't have an
incentive to change their action during
the round if they made the decision in
the beginning of the round after two
minutes with no blocks they have no
reason to change their direction
yes let's define the games utility this
one by one so the utility of a player is
its revenue minus its cost per second so
the revenue per second whatever they get
per block were neglecting fees so just
the blocks they produced per second on
the main chain and the cost is like I
said before the effort the mining power
running during the period were when it
was running we're assuming everybody
spends the same for electricity so
imagine s world and we're taking some
nono exponential decay we take the
averages T goes to infinity now when
mining the cost per second is a constant
C for mining for unit and we're not
mining it's zero oh and I also need to
define the base mining profitability so
this is the ratio between what the miner
will make and what the miner is spending
on the power of X when there is no
attack
when there's an attack this is going to
gentleman there is no attack this is
this ratio Omega B and we're going to
assume that that it's positive it's
negative it means that the attacker is
spending more than she's making and then
she wouldn't mind in the first place we
don't need to attack Chile will only
have Omega B for this presentation but
in the paper
next comes the attackers so the
attackers goal is to stop the chain
which implies that the attacker really
doesn't care about their own chain
revenue the attacker is not a player in
the sense that we're not going to have
them strategy but we are going to look
at what their expenses are for
performing the attack and note here that
the attacker doesn't care whether or not
they produced blocks in the chain
because the goal is to stop the chain
and then any money made on the chain is
irrelevant the attacker is going to
commit to a strategy they're going to
say this is our strategy and this is and
they will follow it and we also have a
rushing level which we denote gamma a
rushing adversary's he is able to hear a
message from another party and propagate
her own message before the original
message reaches the other parties the
attacker can do it perfectly they're
rushing and we have a gram of one if
they cannot do it at all and they're
always there their message will always
arrive second then it will be zero this
is important because default behavior
specifically for Bitcoin so any theorem
it's different for specifically for
Bitcoin is that if you hear of two
blocks of equal height you're going to
prefer the first one in here oh does the
attacker has is able to do to be rushing
then they're able to sneak in their
block early and they take no risk
here's the attack
the attacker along with everybody is
going to try to extend the chain and if
they're able to do this they're going to
publish only the header of the block the
signals to everybody that the attacker
has spent some effort he has now honest
miners have three options these are
their actions right they can stop lose
nothing gain nothing they can SPV mine
on the header only or they can mine
properly as they should by the protocol
and extend the original chain so let's
see what the attacker is going to do in
each of these cases if the miner decides
to mine on essentially ignoring the
header and yeah then they produce a
block and the attacker is going to
publish the block that they generated
this results in a race so we're going to
have some miners following the honest
block and some miners following the
attackers block and you see now where
this gamma applies if this block winds
the attacker blocks win then we have a
sad miner they're going to lose whatever
they made with this block option two for
the honest miner SPV mine they're going
to extend on the header only block in
this case is never going to publish the
header
so this block goes down the drain and
everybody continues mining on the
original honest tree so again said miner
there's no point in doing this and final
option is to stop mining important note
this does not mean so having a single
miner stuff does not mean that the
attack succeeded we need all the miners
to stop if someone else finds a block
either here or here the attack ends and
the Train continues
so far
can you beg to go back over to the
second step the second option
so the attack the honest minor extends
tribe extends the header only publishes
it and then the attacker never publishes
the rest of the block so this becomes
invalid
Oh so let's let's analyze this let's see
what what's going to happen and we're
going to have a Markov chain per
strategy I'll show you how we'll build
them and then we'll compare the
utilities and try to figure out when
stop mining become the equilibrium and
we'll have everybody not mine
so have a bunch of channels and only
show one the the analysis of the
situation where the minor continuous
mining will know will denote the minor
we're talking about by I and the
adversary's a so there are three states
in our chain either no attack so there's
just the the end of the chain from
before there is state one means that the
attacker published the header so we have
a chain in the header and the last stage
two means that there is a race so the
header published and competing block now
if we're in the no attack stage three
things can happen
the attacker can find the block and then
we reach the attack stage we have the
header published the player can find the
block and they make the revenue or some
other play or some other honest players
produces a block and they they get some
revenue if there is an attack going on
then again three things could happen
either another player Minds SPV in which
case the attacker is going to not
publish the rest of the block and the
other player just lost his block what we
don't care we are I remind you we are
mining on the common roots on the full
block so it could be
another player who's mining on the route
like us form the race or it could be the
tree form the race
in all these cases their texts are
always done with a trace sorry starts or
the attack finished ends now if there is
a race there are two options either the
attacker wins they're able to win the
race or someone else wins
so either the us the player I or another
player extends one of the sides of the
race and wins
so yeah that's enough details I think
for now and we have three chains like
these for each of the strategies and the
difference is very minor so in keep
mining what we saw above we are trying
to get us from the ongoing attack like
active attack situation to race here we
are not and here we're SPV mining so
we'll get from active attack to
so to to analyze we need an expression
for the utility we can analyze those
chains and get an expression of the
probabilities and from that we get
expressions for the actual utilities and
note here that these expressions depend
all on the actions of the other players
so whatever we're doing it it matters
whether other how many of the other
players are also SBV mining or also
mining or how many of the others play
are their players stopped when there is
an attack
and the solution concept we're going to
use as iterated elimination of strictly
dominated strategies meaning in our case
we're going to reduce the strategy space
as follows
so first of all SPV mining is always
dominated
a no miner at any point with SPV mine if
they're rational because when they SPV
mine the waste the electricity for
extending a chain and then all this
effort is useless because the attacker
is never going to publish the header and
so the rest of the block for which they
have the header and so they're better
off just not mining so SPV mining is not
an option now we're left only with two
strategies either stop or mine and now
we can calculate this is just a single
single expression so we need the utility
on stuff to be larger than the and then
if this happens like if you know for
sure that when you see a header the
block will never be published then
obviously it's nuts could I get this
behemoth but if most of the honest
miners actually do publish the header
first and then a little bit after that
the block that maybe SPP mining is
better than right so you could that's a
good point you could refine the model to
the case where there is some a small
interval for so for foreign honest
behaving minor or fatty-fatty compliant
like we find they you might receive the
header a little bit before the rest of
the block and so the the situation might
be a bit more delicate our model
simplifies this so either they come if
you're honest they come close enough
that it doesn't matter think that's I
think that's realistic but
like saying fact these people do a
speaking
right because in practice it does in not
taking this attack into account
so assuming rational players sorry it's
assuming honest and rational players I
believe that it would not make sense to
have to publish a header and then not
publish the rest of the block if your
intention is not stopping the blockchain
of making money and so assuming that
after a header you are going to receive
a block is usually a reasonable
reasonable behavior it is I mean history
teaches us that this is not always the
case so we we know historically of cases
where miners were not validating
correctly if you recall there was this
famous fork in Bitcoin routine I think
where miners didn't validate correctly
they were just running on top of the
headers and they lost a lot of money
but for the purpose of our analysis we
were assuming that they would go
together so we will not run into the
situation of rational behavior where
someone tries to publish both the header
and the block and you only get the
header for a meaningful amount of time
otherwise I don't know if I'm the one
who's going to cause if I'm
understanding the question correctly as
you're saying this this would only work
if I know that the attack is going on
everybody's the focus of the attack
attack is against everyone we want to
stop the chain
the goal if if it wasn't clear the goal
is to have this condition hold for every
minor in the system we want everybody to
stop I'll show you a graph of what
happens when it happens gradually but
but what we're looking at this look at
what we're looking for at this point is
when the entire system is going to stop
everybody is going to stop mining so
we're looking to have you stop larger
than you mine for for everyone and this
these expressions depends on the base
profitability which is and we need so
playing a little bit with this
expression we'll get the condition on
the profitability on the base
profitability so if the base
profitability is smaller than this
expression then everybody is going to
stop mining and the expression depends
on the size of the miners in the system
actually the size of the largest miner
the size of the attacker and rushing
so let's look at this graph in this
question in graph form and before I'll
get into the information just in case
you don't believe in math who ran
simulations and you see that they match
quite close with the theoretical curves
and so first let's see what happens is
we change the minor size so you see here
the max based profitability under which
the attack is going to work this is kind
of intuitive right if you're making a
lot of money then getting a small
reduction is not going to cause you to
change your behavior so we need the base
reward to be kind of small for this to
work
they didn't understand sPB's always
dominated are there any honest miners
doing SBB money no never so no SBB
mining they're either mining or stopping
public just a header honest miners will
just ignore this they're not feeling
like I'm showing you that this is this
would be wrong this would stop they
should stop they should not ignore it
the this was the ostrich with her head
in the sand right they can't ignore it
and just continue mining
all the honest miners will just look at
the box or actually there so what oh
yeah let's that's right let's wait with
this for a second so when you get the
header you can verify that the attacker
has spent the effort and they do have
the block with which they can perform
the attack yeah we can do two things
actually three things you can stop
mining because you can continue mining
on the old chain because you ignore
because you ignore math or you can do
SPV mining because you want to lose
money so you don't want to lose money so
you're not going to SPV and you look at
these graphs and you figure out when
it's not going to be worthwhile for you
to attack and the point here is that
this this condition makes sure that
nobody else is going to extend their to
extend the graph everybody else is also
going to stop but I don't have a graph
for this I'm afraid but suppose that
we're in a situation where you decide to
stop because of all of this and you have
the option you can say to yourself well
actually I'm going to be making more
money in the long term so I'm not going
to be myopic I'm going to look em into
the future and say I want the system to
continue working
I should be mining and now we have
others like you that think yeah we
should also be mining we're going to be
making more money in that case you have
in a even higher motivation to stop
mining so if the others are mining
you're going to be making even more
money relatively by stopping when you're
supposed to stop so everybody's
motivation is very strongly to stop
mining it just wait
are you assuming the same cost yeah yeah
we're assuming a flat flat rate
otherwise so if the cost for like power
costs vary then you're interested in
order to understand whether the attack
is going to work out or not you're
interested in the entities with the
cheapest cheapest power yeah
numbers in a little bit so first of all
this we say we set gamma to be 1/2 this
is reasonable if you accept a certain
correction to the Komodos protocol and
then you can actually enforce this and
then we see what happens as we increase
the miners size so if the honest- size
is larger an attacker is going to be
less effective you will need one base
reward to be smaller for the attack to
work out larger miners have an easier
time overcoming the attack by just
extending their chain because they're
less likely to losing the race
and this is setting the minor to 20
percent and then increasing the
attackers rushing ability and the higher
it is there is a wider range of base
profitability when the attack is going
to work this again is the size of the
adversary range is reasonable so now
these are just numbers right what's what
- making twice as much from remaining
then you're spending let's see what the
actual numbers are
so this is a graph we produced for the
profitability over time and you see the
colors change as new hardware as new
hardware is introduced into the market
so newer hardware means better
profitability and we see these small
here right up a little bit when there is
new hardware and the fluctuation is due
to the change this is this is for a
Bitcoin so these are the Bitcoin
exchange rate changing the profitability
margin we kept I mean the interesting
point is the top of the curve here we
kept the s9 here because there they're
still around you see that with with an S
not bit main s 9 minor the profitability
today is about one so unless you're
mining with University electricity or
not we're not making money with an S 9
and the reasonable numbers are about two
so when when things are good in the
market which I guess is not today then
it's going to be higher but when things
are not so great then about two is a
reasonable number and two it's kind of I
mean it's not terrible for us if you
look at this graph so being being a two
is not so bad however two things first
of all the sorry first of all the
rewards from mining are going down in
the market for mining becomes more and
more competitive
and second of all actually before the
second of all I want to show you
something else so this is the analysis
this is a very specific analysis and not
not from the equations I show you I
showed you before so we took here the
minor sizes for Bitcoin on a particular
day a few months ago it's actually not
not not a good spread a not a bad spread
I think and what we did what we did is
we looked at whether the attacker can
stop some of the mining power so reduce
the mining power in the system this is
not a full stop so this is again the
adversary's power and this is the
proportion of rational miners that stop
mining due to an attack so here we allow
some miners to keep on mining and others
to stop mining we find numerically an
optimal an optimal point where they
would stop change and we see what ratio
of the miners stopped mining at this
point and again we check for the
different base profitability values and
you see that if the profitability is
high then that the attacker has to be
really large in order to get any ratio
of the network stop if it's very low
than an attack of a much smaller size so
this is 30% can stop the entire network
it's a gradual process so let me try to
rephrase the attempt so essentially the
model is as you said and the attack is
simply an adversary basically publishes
an SPB header and then all the rational
honest players should stop because they
realized that either one of the things
two things can happen either the guy's
bluffing or not laughing and then you
know I'll get into a race and I'll lose
the race essentially
so they just stopped yeah well we're the
right model for this is like a credible
threat it can be connected cubic he
shows you a Heather he had we have the
block it's very credible right he does
have
it's like I'll show you something like
is something that the attack becomes
less credible when you bring the minor
into the gear the attacker into the game
which we don't do that's an interesting
work to do but this is not this one
we're the attacker for us is is
consistent attacker that does this
attack and everybody knows that they
will do this attack
well no I'm just right it feels like
there's something like you're using a
trick to make this work out but I'm
trying to get my yeah my first thought
was it wasn't like now it wasn't if you
threaten not sort of it's not an empty
threat it's a true threat and the
attacker is willing to spend money in
order to make this work a lot of money
do you think that the attacker will say
I'm actually not going to publish the
block or I'll give up and publish the
block I think this is the question right
so whether so sorry you're asking
whether this is the rational behavior
for the minor will find this question
interesting but we have not addressed it
yet right now we have a miner who is
willing to spend a lot of resources and
they don't care really if they're going
to be able to do this more efficiently
than this attack with me whenever
they're faced with two blocks they
always choose the one with the header
that the block came closest to the
header you won't open this already okay
let's talk about this yeah so the
defense you're proposing is that the
honest miners are going to correct me if
I'm wrong yeah and the attacker is sorry
the honest miner is going to prefer
blocks where the header is fairly close
to the rest of the block
I think it's even worse I think that if
you go there then you can start
implicating the honest miners so you're
if you have any level of network control
you're going to be able I mean you're
going to try and an attacker so if you
introduce this kind of thing into the
protocol then miners can start going
into all sort of different rational
behavior to increase the revenue by
intentionally trying to separate others
headers from their blocks and send their
own blocks close to their headers as
possible so you're making the entire
protocol less less robust
usually okay so yeah I I think I think
the attacker doesn't need a lot of a lot
of control of the network if you're
looking at these differences but what we
do suggest is something I think very
similar to what you said which is we
said it's not perfect but it's better we
we set a threshold so if your header
arrived let's say 30 seconds before the
body of the block then it's suspicious
and if your body or the body of your
block arrived within 30 seconds from the
header then it's not suspicious it might
still happen
always so we're going to keep it as
suspicious and not suspicious
and if we have two blocks one suspicious
one not suspicious we're going to prefer
the non suspicious and then get with
this threshold the attacker really need
excellent control of the network layer
in order to overcome the mechanism
that's not perfect because there might
still be
we don't I'll get to it I'll mention a
few more solutions and this this is not
great something to think about I just
wanted to give you some more bad news so
this is the profitability so the truth
is that we kind of gave ourselves harder
harder life than we needed to because
often you have multiple coins with the
same proof of work mechanism this is
common often due to Forks like Bitcoin
Bitcoin cash and these currencies
because of market powers have similar
profitability because miners do hop from
one to the other in order to maximize
their their utility and so our our new
model actually becomes either
SBV mine keep mining or mine on another
chain so here I'm going to make not zero
but actually I'm going to make money
this makes the attack a lot cheaper so
it brings the ratio down and this is a
graph we made for the profitability
ratio they're not profitability but
profitability ratio between Bitcoin and
Bitcoin cash and we see that there was
some noise when it started but it's
pretty much around one is expected okay
so how can we implement this attack and
so if first of all we can do this
through a separate channel so we have a
biast attack blocks org we go there
and we published blocks when we want to
do the attack and everybody should
should comply
this is also a good way to implicate
others so I don't know if this is the
best attack the other ways to use a
Bitcoin mechanism called called compact
blocks where Bitcoin actually helps us
propagate just the headers so we already
have the mechanism to get the network's
help in propagating the block
another option is doing a zero knowledge
proof so we're going to prove that we
have a block without actually exposing
the block so we'll have the B dos attack
secret blocks org where anyone can go
and verify that we have a block
extending the current chain but no
knowledge of what the block actually is
and now they cannot defend against a
specific block we cannot implicate
either but yeah and the final option we
came up with is using a smart contract
on a separate chain namely theorem this
is like an theoretical version of this
so the attacker is going to place
they're going to issue a smart contract
and they're going to send a commitment
for that smart contract that will give
everybody money if they don't prove that
they have a block within some time so
say I will give the five largest miners
in Bitcoin a huge amount of money if I
don't expose my secret blocks next next
it's my secret block by next month
so either the attack went on and I had
to explore expose my my secret block the
header or otherwise if the attack worked
out I can publish it next month but then
for one month I had I have no money so
this is a success for the attack
I'm willing to publish it someone else
publishes the block then I publish my
own and then the honest parties can
distinguish they can say which block is
there
no no it's more fun than that I want
them to be able to prove that they have
spent the work in order to produce a
block they are able to compete but not
publish the header must be the screen
where you know somebody could extend the
chain but isn't yes yes so so now the
question is the way that works is the
reason I just want to mind my own blog
is that I know that if I find a block
then they will show their own block good
so how does the smart contract get them
to do that the smart contract guarantees
that they present their block within the
next month if they publish it earlier
it's fine
so I want to prove you that I that I can
do the attack
so I'm committing in a smart contract to
lose a lot of money if I don't actually
have the block so if the attack doesn't
work and they have to publish my block
early on then I have an a very I'm very
early on I can produce this proof so say
the block header plus nonce something
like that here's here's a smart contract
that says I have a block and I lose a
lot of money if I don't publish it and
I'm gonna give you the hash of the block
so you can bind the next one if you want
and then now I have a proof of a longer
that I'm not telling everybody I'm still
holding that block secret so nobody can
do anything I can show it to the next
guy you know and and by the way if you
want the header you can also I can also
force you to pay me and I can do right
kind of like the paper Sudoku thing I
can even do reliable
I will reliably give you the header of
the of the block at the tip if you're
paying a lot of money yeah leave it
worse so this is Joe's idea from before
on extortion bribery and yeah so there
are some natural and less natural
extensions to this and the whole concept
of of doing this partial X position and
and the proof of efforts in advance yes
this is this is the first step and we're
looking at some of these
so the first mitigations actually spoke
about already and thanks to tell other
mitigations so one is actually already
implemented in ethereal so I don't know
generally but this specific attack does
not work for ethereal and ethereal
miners get rewarded for blocks that end
up off the main chain so they get a
consolation prize and a significant
consolation prize and this makes the
attack ineffective again this attack
specifically there might be a variant
but this attack specifically doesn't
work because in case of a race everybody
is making some money and our analysis
showed this doesn't work
another thing again this attack
specifically with these limits
specifically
I don't know how robust the mechanism is
against variations of the attack and and
finally you could you could do frequent
difficulty adjustments this would make
the situation much more difficult for
the attacker so if the attacker is able
to reduce the rate of blocks on the main
chain but we know that there's a lot of
time a lot of time has passed if there
might be a point where we're back where
we would like to actually start
extending the chain again because we
know that the chain will immediately
reduce its difficulty making the
profitability much higher you could run
into all sort of temporal effects there
our analysis doesn't it assumes that the
difficulty remains stable so if you want
to do this specifically for for Bitcoin
difficulty adjusts roughly every two
weeks so you would do the attack at the
beginning of the week and then
difficulty adjustment wouldn't affect
you and with this I conclude thank you
very much mining concentration a
medication just we were saying the
larger pools make the attack more
difficult we often think we want less
mining concentration because
yeah this is this is a good point so
there are actually other other cases
where larger pools are a good thing
there is probably some optimal point in
some sense for where you want to be
because you don't want the pools to be
too large and you also don't want them
to be too small and you said I can't
tell you like what the exact size you'd
want it to be and more importantly I
don't think you can make it happen
with existing protocols people try to do
stuff like this we would sort of
naturalistically see adaptation in the
sense of mining pools might combine
properly
right another really quick lesson in
your analysis dude you're sort of
presuming a lot of times kind of
rational miners who understand what's
going on with this attack work
adaptively if you imagine miners are
sort of stupid maybe they maybe sort of
switch strategies fairly randomly but
they pay attention to their
profitability and if they're not
profitable for a period of time then
they're gonna sit down absolutely you
could ignore you could say that the
header only just simply doesn't reach
everyone the incentives for someone
who's not aware of the exact mechanics
of the attack is exactly the same but
they
they would only find out that there are
not as profitable as they should be for
the attack to really work out they need
to know when to stop they would see
something is going on but because their
profitability suddenly goes down and
they're working harder for everybody
else to be making money
everybody is smart and can see ho ok
this attack is gonna succeed I better
quit now the resources and the and the
miners are sort of dumb or idealistic or
something
the attacker can still win just by
forcing them to become unprofitable over
time the numbers might be slightly
different if they're completely not
looking at me they would have to be
pushed out of the market or something
right they're only looking at the
profitability basically and their
strategies are pretty sad what they're
gonna do this preset I'm not entirely
sure this is something to test because
because the question now is not whether
or not I'm going to be mining when there
is an active attack but rather whether
I'm going to be mining at all
that's the same to speaker
[Applause]